something wrong here let's go and poke
it with a stick
[Applause]
oh yeah this one I'm just gonna
straight-up quote because yeah god I
love this episode a lot it's been way
too long since I've watched this one
Amy's choice good there's so much that I
love about this and I'd like it even
more now you knowing what it kind of
indicates about Rory and Amy's
relationship and I part of me was
nervous to rewatch this because I was
like is stuff that goes on with them
later gonna feel betray is this gonna
feel betrayed by stuff that I know is I
know that's totally consistent this is
the the arc of their relationship as a
couple and again I'll probably head back
on this as I continue my rewatch to see
if there are hiccups that I don't
remember but the arc of their
relationship I think is really solid
across the the run of these two
characters so that's phenomenal Matt
Smith he's got he's got so many great
lines in this and I love him flustered
which is very much what he is here like
they see the the cold star that they
might crash into it
I don't know everything why does
everyone expect me to know everything
I'd love him getting flustered and
aggravated and that's part of what the
whole is cuz this is the episode that
opens in Leadworth Upper Leadworth sorry
um we're you know five years later from
the last time we saw them Amy and Rory
Rory settle down Amy's pregnant they're
gonna have the first kid Rory's a doctor
didn't see oh nice local community
everybody lives to a nice ripe old age
and the doctor shows up and they kind of
catch up and then sudden things off and
something dangerous is going on here and
then they keep flashing back to the
TARDIS where they are rapidly
approaching a cold star whereas most
stars radiate heat this one radiates
cold and they're gonna freeze to death
because the TARDIS is dead and is
drifting towards this thing and in both
they are being tormented by Toby Jones
has the dream Lord
who says to them that one of these
realities is fake the other is real
meaning that one of these dangers is
going to kill them but they have to
figure out which one and allow
themselves to die in the fake reality
but if they guess wrong then they're
dead
first of all that's a great fun premise
getting to jump back and forth between
these two concepts which neither of it
this this is also like a really good use
of ideas because neither of these ideas
either the threat in the you know on
earth in Upper Leadworth of these you
know aging people who are secretly
housing a lien z' and those are
dangerous you know that neither that nor
the tardis drifting towards a cold star
is really enough to sustain a full
episode on its own
but it'll sustain half an episode just
nicely and it jumps back and forth
perfectly and I feel like that's worth
point out because there have been
instances during this rewatch where
there have been subplots that annoyed me
not because that they were bad but
because I'm like that could have
sustained an entire episode but it's not
getting its due because it has to share
space with everything else like the
example of Tom ahead is gridlock which
is an episode I like a lot the whole
idea of the moods just being so the
people can just buy happy or forget or
bliss and and what-have-you or sleep I I
feel like that concept in a society and
what would happen to a society that had
this stuff really available could have
been its own episode and it is
integrated into that story but that is
so story primarily about this epic level
traffic jam where people are stuck on
the motorway for years and decades and
generations and this this other idea
about you know moods as drugs has to be
a subplot when I honestly think that
could have been its own thing here I
love that both of these subplots are
simple enough that you wouldn't want to
try and make a whole episode out of that
alone so that's terrific Toby Jones is
such a brilliant reflection of Matt
Smith's doctor because we're
Matt Smith is charming Toby Jones is
smarmy we're Matt Smith has a sense of
authority toby jones has a set of a
sense of sinister threat it's it's
vaguely in the same but it's just
twisted it's not a mirror opposite it's
not like he is everything that doctors
like no he is a lot of what the doctor
is just slightly twisted it's like
taking the characterization of Matt
Smith's doctor and looking after a
funhouse mirror
you can still identify everything but
it's like that's the wrong shape that's
not quite right and I I do think the
dream Lord is a character who needs to
be brought back I don't care how figure
out how its Doctor Who you can think of
ways to bring him back
please somebody bring him back because
he's just he's so good and I mentioned
the relationship between Amy and Rory
that is a huge thing here because this
is the this story is important in the
arc of Amy's relationship not only with
Rory but with the doctor because it's
been an open question since she left
with the doctor and we realized that you
know Rory was waiting to marry her what
does she want and if she truly ever has
to choose only one of them you know what
will she choose and we see her make that
choice under the best circumstances for
us to believe that this is sincerely her
choice that it's not the choice she
thinks she should make or the choice
she's making in the heat you know the
heat of an exciting adventure but like
know when the chips are down this or
this you can't have both what do you go
with
she makes the choice and it's the
perfect circumstances to put her in that
where she makes the choice to choose
spoiler fiance in the episode Rory and I
actually found myself getting choked up
a little bit in the conversation the
tardis after they wake up where
Rory says well wait a minute how did you
how did you know that that wasn't the
real world you know when you decided to
die in that one and be here and she's
like I didn't and it dawns on him what
that means that he had died there and
she couldn't accept that as being the
real world because if he was dead she
didn't want to be there and the weight
of that and his relief and joy of of
whatever doubts he had about this
woman's love for him which would have
been very legitimate because as he
himself out you ran away with another
man the night before our wedding you
watched that wash out of him it's an
amazing performance the two of them have
such sweet sweet chemistry which is
really tough to do given that Karen
Gillan also has to sell that sense of
restlessness that sense of needing more
than just you know a quiet home life
which clearly Rory would be very happy
in so for her to be able to sell that
while at the same time having a strong
enough connection to somebody who
obviously would tie her down and to sell
that relationship without feeling like
it's holding her back this I mean the
this team this trio while Matt Smith is
not my favorite dr. Amy is not my
favorite companion Rory's not my
favorite companion the three of them
together
I do think are my favorite TARDIS team
that we've had in modern era Doctor Who
because the dynamic is so finely tuned
and has much more development over time
it's not that the relationships between
the three of them actually change all
that much but the way in which things
happen in circumstances happen where the
audience gets affirmations as to exactly
what this dynamic is are really well
paced across the life of these
characters on the show so it's not that
the relationship between Amy and Rory
chain
is all that much from when Amy starts
traveling with the doctor to the end of
their time together it changes a little
and there's little bits and there's
nuances here and there but it's not a
massive shift in the relationship it's
not like what happened with rose and
Mickey where it completely changed but
there is just moments and episodes like
this that give you this insight into
what makes them tick as a couple and the
pace at which those sorts of episodes
happen and the episodes themselves where
we get that affirmation are really
really well done this is a phenomenal
episode it is fun it is touching it is
exciting it's got terrific before I mean
it's basically a forehand or mean we
technically have you know supporting
cast because we've got you know the the
killer old people and oh he was a cool
touch that I hadn't noticed before the
doctor from the very beginning is
insisting that the Leadworth reality is
not real and that the TARDIS is he
insists that from the get-go and yet in
Leadworth he gets in this car and he
keeps stopping the car to pile in people
to help them get away even in a reality
that he doesn't believe he still stops
to help people who probably aren't real
I love that I never caught that before
that never clicked for me before that
that was what he was doing cuz again
from the get-go he's like oh one of
these realities is false it's that one
that was a rubbish reality I don't
believe that for an instant but he still
stops to help people in reality he
doesn't even think is real yeah I feel
like that says almost everything about
the doctor right there it's so good and
the dynamic and the tension between the
characters as the scene and the tension
builds is so excellent and like I said
the doctor getting flustered all of them
getting flustered because it's a
situation that won't stay still they
could deal with either one of these but
once they put it it keeps yanking them
back and forth and everybody just it
just the whole thing builds and then it
has a wonderful emotional based climax
which at this point my life
I appreciate emotional climax is a bit
more than I appreciate action climaxes
and to emotionally pivot it on Rory
dying for the first time and Amy's
decision to commit herself to be with
him possibly at the risk of dying
herself that's that's awesome
great villain great story great dynamic
great relationships great episode I love
this thing I really really really do
Amy's choice
Yuri watched it lately what'd you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's a bunch of stuff down
there to do as well because there's
buttons and links you can like and
subscribe you can support me on patreon
even as little as a dollar a month is a
big help and gets you access to things
such as the ability to vote on topics or
see the docket for the upcoming month
plus you know a bunch of other links
down there besides my social medias
Instagram and Twitter and link to the
book I wrote and blah blah blah blah
blah all down in the description click
on them or don't you don't have to
because at the end of the day you are
the council I'm just rounding the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]